لكن يمكنني أن أخبرك أن الولايات
المتحدة قد حذرت بالطبع السلطات الأوكرانية من
أنه من
الممكن أن تكون هناك
ضربات أه غارات جوية
هجمات صاروخية على أماكن مختلفة في
جميع أنحاء البلاد بما في ذلك
العاصمة كييف الآن لا أفعل  لا أعرف ما إذا كان
هذا ما نشهده الآن ،
لكنها صدفة رائعة
أن أسمع هذه الانفجارات
في كييف الآن ، دعني أقفز في
غضون دقيقة بعد أن ألقى فلاديمير بوتين هذا
الخطاب ، نعم بعد دقائق من الخطاب
أريد فقط.  هل سمعت
أي انفجارات مشابهة منذ
أن كنت في كييف
لا لا لا على الإطلاق ،
هذه هي المرة الأولى
التي نسمع فيها شيئًا كأنه كان
صامتًا تمامًا في هذه المدينة
طوال الليل ولأجل
في الأسابيع العديدة الماضية ، لم نر
أي شيء على الإطلاق في الواقع ، لم أسمع أبدًا
أي شيء كهذا في كييف على مدار
السنوات التي أتيت فيها إلى هنا
وأبلغ من هنا ، لذلك هذا هو
في المرة الأولى ، لكن يبدو أنها ستكون
أكثر من مجرد مصادفة ، يمكنني سماع
التذمر الآن ،
وأنت تعلم ماثيو ، هل المكان آمن في المكان
الذي تحدده بدقة ،
نعم أعتقد أنه
آمن نسبيًا في الوقت الحالي.
هناك واحدة أخرى لدي سترة واقية من الرصاص
هنا ،
اسمح لي فقط أن أحصل عليها على
الهواء مباشرة ، أبق أوكرانيا ماثيو
سنلتزم بك ، آه ماثيو
على سطح ، آه في وسط كييف ، يخبرنا بذلك
وفقط من أجل  لأول مرة
منذ لحظات فقط شاهدت على الهواء مباشرة في هذا
البرنامج انفجارات مرة أخرى هو لا يعرف
بالضبط ما هي تلك الانفجارات لكنه
يقول إنها المرة الأولى
أه التي يسمعها منذ أن
كان في كييف وهو يحاول أن يضعها على
النار.  سترة الآن
للتأكد من
أنه
آمن